[Music]
[Music]
it
is seven o'clock which means you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster nhs england says
there will be a significant reduction
in vaccine supplies next month yet both
pfizer and
astrazeneca insist that they're on
course to meet their domestic
uk delivery commitment so what is the
issue
and could it affect the pm's roadmap out
of lockdown we'll be asking the housing
secretary robert generick about that
and his new plans to get more rough
sleepers off our streets
in a few moments time but also coming up
this morning
helping nhs staff to communicate whilst
cocooned
in ppe we'll be chatting to the security
expert and the surgeon about the new
hands-free systems allowing hospital
workers to talk to each other
on the front line also on the programme
at the top of our game we'll be chatting
to the football coaching grandmother
who's netted herself a national awards
and high praise
from none other than the england manager
himself that's coming your way
at 10 tonight on this thursday the 18th
of march
a row over the rollouts pfizer and
astrazeneca reject
nhs claims that the uk is facing a
covered vaccine shortage saying there is
no
threat to domestic supplies
it comes as the european medical
medicines agency prepares to make a
decision
about the safety of the astrazeneca jack
admits concerns
about blood clots
potential breach of human rights
concerns that more than 500
do not resuscitate decisions were made
during the pandemic
without consent
immigration overhaul reports that the
home secretary wants to send asylum
seekers to processing centres
in other countries
building blocks to house the homeless an
extra 212 million pounds to tackle rough
sleeping
critics say it is not enough it won't
provide the long-term
permanent support we need for people to
end homelessness
[Music]
a bit disappointing for some today
across the east with some rain coming in
across eastern and south east england
where it'll feel cool but for others
there will be some warm sunshine
developing more details on that coming
up before half past
morning all pfizer and astrazeneca well
they've both denied claims by nhs
england that there will be a significant
reduction
in covering vaccine supplies to the uk
next month and with both drugs giants
insisting that they remain on course
to meet their domestic delivery
commitments concerns have been raised
that a slowdown in the vaccine rollout
could have an impact on the prime
minister's roadmap out of
lockdown let's take a look at the main
developments over the vaccine rollout
this morning starting with this well
last night nhs england sent out
a letter to vaccination centers across
the country warning that supplies
would be significantly constrained in
april they're issuing new guidance it
said that under 50s should not be
offered a first jab
except in exceptional circumstances
uh well the uk's two main drugs
manufacturers fizer and astrazeneca
have both in their own way rejected the
claim insisting that there is no threat
to the domestic supply chain they say
they remain on course to meet their
delivery commitments
and deny that they are facing disruption
still the eu has threatened to block
vaccine exports to the uk
and other countries with higher vaccine
rollout
all this as the european medicines
agency will announce its verdict on the
safety
of the astrazeneca jab later today uh
well let's bring in our political
correspondent rob powell
at joining us on the show um look plenty
of questions to be put into the housing
secretary of course on his brief but on
covet but
but at its core do we really understand
what on earth is going on
with this vaccine supplied moment so
there's still not a terribly large
amount of clarity on it in part that's
because the government haven't laid out
or been terribly transparent about
how many vaccine supplies are coming in
when and where from
but i think it's important to read the
statement that astrazeneca put out last
night quite carefully
they talk about no problems but they
importantly talk about no problems
to their domestic uk supply chain now
that matters because astrazeneca
manufactures or at least has licensing
agreements to manufacture the jab
abroad as well such as in india and it
is those global supplies of jabs
that are thought to be the reason behind
this significant
reduction i think one of the big
questions for government this morning
is in terms of its timetable out of
lockdown
is that hooked to the public targets for
vaccine rollout so end of july for
everyone
mid april for over 50s because if it is
government and ministers last night were
saying
that actually we're still on target to
meet that but around westminster the
whispers have been that if you look at
the current pace of rollout the
government is going faster
than those expected target dates so has
that map out of
lockdown been hooked to the public
targets or has it been hooked
to the potentially accelerated private
targets that have been talked about in
westminster
uh well let's hope we get a little bit
of clarity in that in the not too
distant future for now rob thanks very
much indeed
uh but as we always do let's take a
quick look at the latest
data in terms of the uk's at battle
against coronavirus
a further 5758
new cases were recorded in the latest
24-hour periods
uh in addition 141 more deaths now that
takes the total number of people who
died with
covert 19 to 125
800 the figures also show that 25.27
million first doses of a vaccine
have now been given
and as we've been saying the housing
secretary robert generic
joins us now once again on the program
mr general always good to see you
uh particularly this early hour um
we've got a lot to talk about on your
brief but can we just start with the
issues
such as they may be around vaccination
why has there been an instruction a
change
to the schedule in terms of vaccination
how much of a delay do we see being
built into the system
well we do think there are going to be
some supply issues in the weeks ahead
but this isn't anything that people
should be worried about we're still on
course
to meet our targets that's to vaccinate
all of the groups one to nine by the
middle of april and all
adults to receive their first vaccine by
the end of july
nobody who has an appointment should be
concerned you're still going to get your
second vaccine all those appointments
will be honored but we always said right
from the beginning that
a new manufacturing process would have
its lumps and bumps and that has been
the case in the past and
i'm sure it will be in the future we're
sourcing vaccines from all over the
world and
we are experiencing occasionally some
issues and that's led to this
uh this issue with some supply in the
coming weeks but
as i say the main thing is we're still
very much on course we've still got line
of sight
to deliver the vaccines and to meet our
targets
just to be really specific and indeed on
something you just mentioned there
problems in obtaining the vaccine from
around the world there's a suggestion
this morning that perhaps the
the issue as regards the the az oxford
vaccine is a problem in india where they
do produce is is that your understanding
well i'm not going to get into the
specific contracts that we have with
different manufacturers
we're sourcing vaccines from many
countries all over the world
it's a very complex international supply
chain and as i say
that does mean occasionally we will
experience issues and
and that is what we've experienced right
now
but there is no reason to be concerned
we are
on course to meet our target which is to
get those first categories of one to
nine
vaccinated by the middle of april and
that was always a challenging target
remember we only met our target in
mid-february
with a couple of days grace and so the
targets the prime minister has set us
are not easy ones but we are on course
uh to to to to to achieve that one
and myself matt hancock nadeem zahawi
the government we have line of sight
that we've got enough vaccines to do
that and so that's the main thing and
that's what we're focused on right now
indeed and and of course as you as
you've done as you alluded to the health
sector yesterday in in downing street
made it very clear that those
those deadlines those targets would
would still be met there is a little bit
of concern though
on whether or not this might have some
impact uh
on the roadmap itself i mean is the is
the
is the map roadmap actually based on
those kind of confirmed vaccination
targets on those dates that the health
secretary
still stuck to yesterday well the the
vaccine rollout
is our route out of this the more people
we vaccinate the easier it will be to
open up our society and get us back to
the way of life that we all
want to see there's no reason to believe
that the road map is affected by
uh this temporary shortage in supply
uh the the main thing is that we are on
course to meet the targets that the
prime minister
set us up getting the categories one to
nine which is all the over fifties
including the
uh the clinically extremely vulnerable
below that age vaccinated by
the middle of april so there's no
concern that
uh we're off course with the road
matcher capture just one last question
on the vaccine and it is a distance from
your brief so you may well not know this
but does the moderna jab start coming
into circulation uh
in april i don't know to be honest the
the exact date that uh the modern chap
will be in use within
the uk uh obviously we have uh the
orders placed
and uh we'll be using them as quickly as
they they come into the country
i actually apolo apologies that
secretary said i i
inadvertently misspoke that one more
question on on the vaccines
what what do you make of the the saber
rattling that we're seeing from amongst
others ursula wonderland
the the threat that somehow that the eu
could have a rather spurious
interpretation to my eyes at least of
article 22
and intervene in vaccinations and
delivery of vaccines that we have
bought that we have paid for that are on
contractual basis hours
that the eu might step in to intervene
there well i was surprised
and disappointed by those comments but
the prime minister had spoken earlier in
the year
to ursula vanderlian and she gave a very
clear commitment
which was that the eu would not engage
in this sort of activity
that contractual responsibilities would
be honored
uh and that's exactly what we intend to
do and i i hope
and expect the eu to to stick to their
side of the bargain
as well it isn't at all helpful if we
enter into this sort of conversation
that's not the way
the uk is behaving or wants to behave in
the future
we all need to work together to get
through this
supplies of vaccines rely on very
complex
international manufacturing supply
chains as we've just said
and so everybody needs to uh to have
free trade vaccines and not get into
this sort of
this sort of difficulty um talk to us a
little bit then about about rough
sleeping the rough sleeping
accommodation program of course
did serve to take thousands of people
off of the streets at a time when
you know everyone was very very
concerned about the the spread of the
pandemic we certainly knew a lot less
and
we're moving on to kind of the second
stage of that now
that's right a year ago almost to the
day we launched everyone in which
had a simple objective of asking those
people who were sleeping rough on the
streets are most vulnerable to kova 19
to come in into safe and secure
accommodation it was hugely successful
we ended up bringing in over 37 000
people
who are either sleeping on the streets
or in otherwise pretty precarious
situations like sofa surfing with
friends
and relatives most of those people have
now been able to move on into better
accommodation
either social housing the private rental
sector or what's called move on
accommodation
which is temporary with accommodation
with wrap around care
about 27 000 people have been given that
sort of help over the course of the last
year
but we still got many people in
temporary emergency accommodation
and today we're putting in place further
support
so that we can build up good quality
accommodation to help those people to
access it and begin to rebuild their
lives we've secured over 400 million
pounds
and today we're releasing the next 200
million of that so that
charities and local councils across the
country can invest in
up to 6 000 new move on units over the
course of this parliament and that will
give us
a new national asset of accommodation so
that if people are sleeping rough
they can be moved on given a home and
then begin to
rebuild their lives yeah get help for
substance abuse
there will be no one who is what sorry
apologies minutes we've got a finite
amount of time
there will be no one working in this
sector that will not welcome additional
money of course th
they will welcome additional money the
question is whether or not it goes quite
so far
it quite far enough i mean the
statistics as you were mentioning there
37 and a half thousand people
in essence helped uh as a result of
everyone in but that i mean that figure
there is obviously going to be a
disparity but that figure of 37 and a
half thousand
is a country mile away from the
department's own estimates of
of how many rough sleepers there were in
the country it was roughly 4
300 in march 2020. i mean you've been on
a bit of a learning curve here
but are we still on course to eradicate
homelessness by
2024 yes i think we are
by that we mean that nobody should have
to sleep rough
on the streets i think we've learned
from everyone in that there will always
be some people
who do for a variety of complex reasons
even at the height of
the lockdown last spring when we asked
everybody in the country who was
sleeping rough on the streets
to come in we still found a small number
of people who chose not to
but our objective is that there is good
care that everybody is offered
accommodation
within at least a night or so of being
seen on the streets and that is what
we're working towards
we made huge progress last year the
number of people sleeping rough on the
streets
fell by about 37 according to
the statistics that were published a
month ago that's a major step forward
but
there will be big challenges ahead and
the strategy that we are putting in
place is not just one of housing
but it is also one of health making sure
there is proper support for people for
their mental health
and for substance abuse which is a
really significant factor
in why people end up on the streets and
then
the the issues that they face when
they're on the streets
okay minister just just before just
before we we wrap up um
there's a policy initiative i think from
pretty patel that will raise a few
eyebrows
doing the rounds this morning few
reports that asylum seekers could be
sent from the
united kingdom asylum seekers who have
arrived in the united kingdom
could be sent to to third countries
to have their asylum uh application
process
what is the thinking behind this and in
what way will this
deter people from making the journey to
the uk in the first place
well this isn't uh a announcement by the
home sector is the speculation on work
that she is doing
and uh we'll be saying more on in the
weeks ahead so
i i can't give you all the answers this
morning but it is extremely important
that we have a robust immigration system
and that those people coming to the
country
to seek asylum can do so in safety we
don't want
anyone's lives to be put at risk we
don't want people to be at the hands of
people traffickers we've seen people
including young children
dying making perilous crossings across
the channel
that isn't something that we want to see
and so if there are safer and better
ways of doing that
then we should be exploring them and
that's exactly what the home secretary
is doing
mr generic good to see you this morning
thanks for being with us
lots more still to come on the show this
morning in about 15 minutes time we're
going to be speaking uh on the issue of
homelessness
to the founder of the big issue john
bird that 12 the 212 million pound
funding announcement
at the mr generic was just described
immediately after that we'll be speaking
to labour's rachel reeves asking why the
party
is backing calls for an immediate public
inquiry into the handling of the
pandemic
at 20 past state as restrictions begin
to ease we'll be speaking to the head
of hayes travel about the demand for
booking holidays abroad
and the pressure on the travel industry
let's take a look at a few of the other
stories at making the news this
morning and the new report claims that
delaying the winter lockdown
caused up to 27 000 extra deaths in
england the resolution foundation think
tank
highlights the huge mistake which should
be central to any public inquiry
into the uk's handling of covet 19. the
report also highlights two key successes
in the pandemic response the vaccine
rollout
and support to protect businesses and
employees
thousands of leukemia patients will be
offered a new cancer treatment
after health officials said it was
suitable to be used on the nhs
those in england with incurable blood
cancer will be able to take the pills
which act as an alternative to
chemotherapy
the scottish government says the
nation's railways will be nationalized
by the end of march next year the
scotrail franchise currently run by
abello will be taken over by the
government as an
operator of last resort when the dutch
company's contract runs out in 2022
the scottish transport secretary has
said scott rail staff will keep their
jobs under the new plans
which have been welcomed by unions
the fashion industry will have to
contribute to the cost of recycling
clothes by the end of next year
under new government proposals to cut
textile wastes the industry is estimated
to account for four percent
of yearly global carbon emissions and
over nine hundred thousand
tons of textiles are thrown out by
households
every year
the eu's medicine regulator will release
details of its review into the safety
of the oxford az vaccine later today
several countries including
germany france and italy have halted
roll outs
as a precaution over safety concerns
linked to blood clots
all this is the european european
commission president warned
that she may block vaccine exports to
countries
mass manufacturing their own vaccine our
europe correspondent adam parsons
reports
today europe's medicines regulator will
announce its verdict on the safety of
the astrazeneca vaccine
its use has been suspended in most eu
countries to investigate a possible link
to a rare form of blood clot vaccine is
expected to be cleared
again for public use but the controversy
over the people behind this british
product
may not be over the president of the
european commission
caustic in her criticism saying
astrazeneca had persistently failed to
deliver the number of doses that europe
had ordered
and paid for and she raised the specter
that the eu could respond
by stopping the export of vaccines to
the uk
if the situation does not change we will
have to reflect on how to make
exports to vaccine producing countries
dependent on their level of openness
so we are exporting a lot to countries
that are
themselves producing vaccines and
we think this is an invitation to be
open
so that we also see experts from those
countries coming back
to the european union
the government's response to that threat
to an air of shock that commitments to
open supply chains were being threatened
we expect those assurances and legal
contracted supply to be respected
frankly
i'm surprised we're having this
conversation is normally what the
uk and the eu team up with to object
when other countries
with less democratic regimes than our
own engage in that kind of brinkmanship
this is a round that now engulfs
politics public health and public
sentiment
that is a very combustible mix
especially when european leaders
are under pressure for leading a
sluggish vaccine rollout
europe's problems in dealing with this
kovic crisis are obvious and they may be
about to get worse
in many countries the rate of infection
has now
gone up steeply in germany italy
and france and that probably means
more restrictions is a city
and a continent hobbled by nervousness
and uncertainty
the line where politics stops and the
business of vaccines starts
is becoming very hard to define adam
parsons sky news
paris the care quality commission
has warned that individuals human rights
may have been breached during the
pandemic
after it found more than 500 cases where
do not resuscitate decisions were made
that had not been discussed with the
patients or their families
the commission found that some were
unaware that a decision had been made
about their loved ones treatment
and has called for government ministers
to get involved
in tackling the issue so guys ali
fortescue has been taking a closer look
at the story from the newsroom morning
ali i mean this is
this is quite something isn't it 500
cases where
the individual or the people that were
in a guardian position
did were not even talked to about a dnr
order
it is quite something i mean we are
potentially talking about hundreds
of human rights breaches as you say it
was something
that i was concerned about already which
is why the care quality commission were
asked to do
this rapid review about how these dna
are
do not attempt to assassinate
resuscitation decisions were being made
and as you say they think that in more
than 500
cases the family and the patient
themselves might not have actually
been told that the dnar decision was
made which potentially means
that they would not have been
resuscitated would not have
had a life life-saving resuscitation
it's worth saying that
in most cases these sorts of
resuscitations
do not actually mean that the patient
survives
but it can be life-saving the cqc were
concerned that a blanket approach had
been taken with particular groups for
example people with learning
difficulties and they say that in part
this was down to the unprecedented
pressure from the pandemic bad record
keeping but there were underlying
issues too charities unsurprisingly have
been voicing
their concern age uk saying this calls
for a complete
overhaul of the system and we've been
speaking um to
another charity compassion in dying who
interestingly say that this has really
brought spotlight onto end of life
care and more clarity is needed either
way
for families about how these decisions
should be made
do not attempt recitation decisions are
an important part of good
of life care and at compassion and dying
we find repeatedly that they give
people peace of mind so during the
pandemic
calls to our information line doubled
and hundreds of people actually
contacted us
wanting help to refuse potentially
harmful cpr through a do not resuscitate
form
and i think at a time with great anxiety
and uncertainty
people actually wanted practical support
to know what they needed to do to retain
some sense of control and some sense of
peace of mind
now nhs england say that the nhs has
repeatedly instructed
local clinicians and services that the
blanket
dna cpr decisions would be unacceptable
and the access to treatment and care for
people
should be and is made on an individual
basis
in consultation with family and carers
and the care quality commission have
said that they
want ministers to work with the care
sector
and to oversee a group to make sure that
this can't happen again
ali thank you a couple of other stories
making the headlines
this morning tens of thousands more
people should be prescribed
nature walks group gardening and art
classes on the nhs
in a bid to improve physical and mental
health that's according to a report from
the royal colleges of psychiatrists
and occupational therapists which say
many are missing out on social
prescribing
even though it could help combat the
mental health fallout from the pandemic
letting toddlers play frequently on
tablets
phones and game consoles could be
putting a bit higher risk of emotional
and behavioral problems
when they start school that's according
to new research from the finnish
institute of health and welfare
which found the increased screen time
has multiple risks for children
google has removed more than 3 billion
adverts for violating its policies in
2020
including just under 100 million related
to the ongoing coronavirus pandemic
the company has revealed the annual ads
safety report shows it suspended over
1.7 million advertiser accounts
for breaking the company's rules
the welsh goat population has rocketed
after a contraception drive
was canceled due to the pandemic you
might remember these pictures from last
year
when the goats of great arm headland
roamed the deserted streets
of nearby london in lockdown well during
the latest lockdown
the goats have ventured even further
after numbers rose
stop it sparking concerns that as
restrictions ease the animals who are
used to having the streets to themselves
might actually be in some danger as the
traffic begins
to rebuild
and we'll have much more on that story
as and when we get it time to check in
and see how the weather is looking this
morning
isabel standing by and it's about am i
wrong it it felt just a little bit
cooler this morning as i force myself
out of bed
basically you just want to talk about
the goats i don't think you're
interested in the weather at all uh yeah
we'll feel a little bit cooler neil
next couple of days particularly across
the southeast fresher and there'll be a
frost on friday night but before that
comes
let's take a look some of the warmth
we've got in store today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
so the cooler air that will be coming in
through tomorrow and the next couple of
days will be
to the east of this frontal system here
so this frontal system comes in across
eastern england gives some pretty dire
weather for eastern england
and the southeast today as that clears
westwards overnight tonight
there'll be some sunnier weather
tomorrow but it will feel a little
chilly now today though
big story really is that across the
north when sunshine becomes rather more
widespread
after a bit of a cloudy start
particularly northern england scotland
you'll find that temperatures shoot up
to 16 to potentially 18 celsius there a
beautiful afternoon for some
across central and northern britain
really nice in that sunshine but
actually quite disappointing where you
hold on to cloud
and obviously disappointing where you
have that rain in eastern england but as
i hinted
at that we'll move in land and peter out
tomorrow sunshine following
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
izzy thank you still to come on
breakfast this morning
a funding boost for new homes and
support for rough sleepers but does it
go far enough
we'll be speaking to the founder of the
big issue that's coming your way next
journalism is under attack it's clearly
marked as press
the right has actually been declared you
have to have the facts
i will stand in the way of the enemy you
have to have key evidence on camera
because people are doubting everything
you are further pushing the agenda that
is condemning all of us to prove
wrong to expose corruption
to show the truth i don't think any
journalist wants anything more than that
[Music]
we've all missed so much in our lives
over the last 12 months but maybe
holidays are towards the top of that
list
the excitement of planning booking and
then traveling is something that we all
look forward to in our year
so we're delighted that on monday of
next week we'll be putting on sale
holidays sailing in the uk coastal
waters
of the uk on our flagship britannia
and our newest ship iona so giving
people the opportunity to break the norm
and get away and have that ultimate
staycation on our ships with all the
incredible food
and entertainment that's to offer
one of the things i think we can be very
proud of as a nation
is our vaccination program and current
estimates show that a
huge number of people will be vaccinated
by this summer
and our first sailing is in actual fact
the 27th of june
so we're anticipating a very large uh
audience
being able to book onto our holidays but
as you're right
we are asking our guests to prove that
they've had
uh they are vaccinated they've had their
second dose
and then we will welcome them on board
to give them an incredible holiday
i'm tom cheshire and i'm skye's asia
correspondent based here in beijing
this police officer was shot through the
calf we aim to be the best
and most trusted place for news
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the housing secretary
robert generic has told the program this
morning
that the government is expecting a
vaccine rollout slow down
next month caused by in his words global
supply issues
but mr generic said this shouldn't have
an impact on the road
out of a lockdown we're sourcing
vaccines from many countries
all over the world it's a very complex
international supply chain
and as i say that does mean occasionally
we will experience issues and
and that is what we've experienced right
now there's
no reason to believe that the road map
is affected by
uh this temporary shortage in supply uh
the
the main thing is that we are on course
to meet the targets that the prime
minister
status us up getting the categories one
to nine which is all the over 50s
including the
uh the clinically extremely vulnerable
below that age vaccinated by
the middle of april so there's no
concern that
we're of course with the roadmap the
housing secretary
also announced 212 million
pounds in funding to build new homes and
support rough sleepers
it follows a report that revealed the
true scale of the problem
nine times worse than the official
government estimate
now let's speak now to john byrd of
course the founder of the big issue
who's joins us now
on the program from cambridge john great
to see you this morning um
and of course plenty for us to talk
about in terms of the latest we've been
hearing from from robert jenner but
but from from your perspective to what
extent did that that everyone in
initiative actually work in in getting
some of the most vulnerable people in
society clearly
those that are sleeping rough off the
streets and and somewhere warm during
the pandemic
uh it worked remarkably well considering
that the government no government
had ever since the victorian period
taken any responsibility for people on
the streets they've looked upon them as
a
necessary decoration of our
of our society and our democracy so the
government for the first time
uh coordinated loads of organizations to
come together to
help to remove as many people from the
streets they didn't manage to get
everybody there was
probably two or three thousand they
didn't get but it was a magnificent
achievement very much like the the
pandemic
um you know the inoculation
program and very showing that we can do
incredible things if we put our minds to
it and we get the government
to do it now obviously we've got to go
further forward can i ask a very simple
question of you
aren't you surprised at how expensive it
is
to run homelessness he's given us a
couple hundred million
uh rough sleeping he's given us a couple
hundred million a few months
ago now he's gonna give us another
couple hundred million is it ridiculous
the amount of money we spend on rough
sleepers
because we never face up to the fact
that these people are a
public health problem a public health
need
uh it's a violation of human rights to
actually
be on the streets and all we're doing in
a sense is responding to the
effects and never dealing with the cause
well
john perhaps perhaps you can explain
just a little bit more about where where
all that money then
then gets spent i mean the thing the
thing that that surprises me is of
course
when you look at the the figures of the
people that were covered by the scheme
let's say just
for the sake of rounding up 37 and a
half thousand
you also look at the housing
department's estimates of how many rough
sleepers
there are and that was in the low single
digit thousands now of course
you know the the figure of the 37.5 000
would have included lots of people who
were
sofa surfing who weren't able to stay at
friends houses but there's a big old gap
isn't there
well the enormous gap is that i mean you
can't always blame the government for
figures which have been carried on the
way the
figures are measured because a lot of
the measuring is done locally
by local councillors and organizations
the real problem to me is that this
government came in in 2019
and has immediately run into the fact
that we are still
treating homeless people on the streets
as
almost a fixed asset and my big problem
is when are we going to get this
government or any government to say okay
when are we going to end this enormous
catastrophe
that has hit our streets and as you say
your figures
really do prove that it's not a minor
consideration it is a major
consideration
when i was a lad when i was a rough
sleeper there was hardly anybody around
because the police stopped you from
doing it
now we have a the police have turned
their back the local authorities
never have enough money to help people
on the streets
so what happens is that you through
austerity
people have ended up on the streets i
want to know
when is the strategy to end homelessness
on the streets when is the strategy
that is much more important than any
temporary measure is this temporary
measure
going to turn into permanent homes and
wrap around support systems for people
who have the demons that drive them onto
the street addressed
i mean the the government has put a date
on it of course i believe 2024 for for
an end
for an end to rough sleeping but i mean
later this year john i think i'm writing
saying you know the big issue will have
been around for
for 30 years for three decades and you
you've been banging this drum for a long
long time
and successive governments have have
either been unable or unwilling to to
deal with the problem i mean do you
honestly believe
in your heart of hearts that we can end
rough sleeping in the uk
uh i don't know whether you can end it
because there's always people
percolating dropping down
but you can stop it you can say we are
not going to accept
the violation of human rights that rough
sleeping is the fact that you're going
to die
before anybody else you're going to have
mental health problems you can have
physical health problems
i think you can stop it but the way to
stop it is to create the communities
that are much cheaper than spending
billions as has happened over the time
that we've been running the big issue
billions that have spent
on responding to rough sleeping on
accommodating rough sleeping
rather than building the therapeutic
communities which would enable us
to take the demons out of people who are
caught in the track of homelessness
um i'd say you know what we did 20 30
years ago was we
wanted to help homeless people off the
streets and we realized
that the best thing to do that was to
give them something to do
a way of making their own money so they
weren't getting into grief
i do believe that this government the
first government i've ever known
whether you agree with them their
political complexion or not
has raised the issue for all of us
we can do something about it good to see
you this morning john thanks very much
for being with us
thank you now almost a
year ago if you can imagine it the uk
entered its first coronavares lockdown
with
our lives changing forever the questions
though
over how britain has handled this
pandemic have been raised for months but
now berea families
and indeed politicians are urging the
government to join them
in calls for a public inquiry labour's
rachel reeves george is once again
on the program ms reeves always good to
see you do hope you're well um
just just give us a little bit of detail
about this the this the
the public inquiry the scope that you
would
have it and when you would see it start
well i think that families have got to
be front and center of this
those people who have lost loved ones
and i recently met
with some of those families and that
meeting will stay with me and those
stories will stay with me for the rest
of
my life and what i'm hearing from
bereaved families
is that they need to understand better
what happened and they are they are
desperate really for lessons to be
learned from what happened because
i don't think any of us think that this
virus has gone away
that there won't be other viruses and
diseases in the future
and that we must learn from what we've
gone through in the last
year so that something can be
salvaged from all of this and families
now
as you say neil a year on want this
public inquiry to begin
i think that we all know there must be
some inquiry at some stage
but let's get on with it so that we can
learn lessons
this summer now the roadmap is supposed
to be completed
on the 21st of june that seems to me to
be the perfect opportunity
to get this inquiry up and running so
that we can
rapidly learn lessons and then get that
justice and that
closure and those answers for those
people whose lives have been most
profoundly affected by this
we we did though hear from jonathan
fantam yesterday on the on the issue of
a public inquiry and he suggested that
it would be a distraction
look i i think it is up in the end to
the government to decide
when an inquiry will happen but it's got
to be a question of when
and not if and now i think there should
have been a rapid review last summer
to better prepare us for what we then
faced in the autumn and winter
and i think if that had happened we
could have saved lives
in the autumn and winter and i think we
must
learn that lesson as well and now use
this opportunity of the summer and the
end of the roadmap
to get this inquiry up and running now
of course it's going to mean that people
are going to have to give
evidence and that we need a greater
understanding of it
but i think it is essential i think it
can help all of us it can help the
government it can help the nhs
because whether it is issues around ppe
test and trace
the situation in our care homes all of
those
need to be better understood so that we
can better learn lessons for the future
but just just in terms of the the period
that you just mentioned kind of november
december that the
beginning of this beginning of this year
are you saying that the the inability of
the government to learn lessons from
what went before that
led to people losing their lives over
christmas new year
last summer the government focused on
eat out to help out
i think the focus last summer should
have been preparing
our nhs and our systems for what the
autumn and windsor was likely to throw
at us i think that was a missed
opportunity
and the government didn't learn the
lessons we were too slow to lock down
a year ago we were too slow in the
autumn and we were too slow at christmas
if there hadn't been that review last
summer perhaps some of those mistakes
that had been made in march
might not have been made in the autumn
and winter and perhaps
by mistakes you mean decisions taken by
the government which led to people
either suffering serious illness or
perhaps even losing their lives
the government were told by sage to have
a circuit break in the autumn
it took weeks for that circuit break to
be put into place
people were urging the government in the
roundup to quit to christmas
to lock down the five days of mixing
was going to be disastrous in terms of
numbers of lives lost the government
were
too slow to take those decisions and
that's why i'm saying
that a public inquiry is essential it's
essential for those people
who have lost loved ones to understand
what happened in the decisions made
but it's also essential to learn lessons
to save lives in the future
and that's why we're saying that now is
the time for that public inquiry
so we can better understand but most
crucially
learn the lessons so that never again do
we experience what we've experienced in
the last year
with the 120 lives what did you make of
that
what did you make of the evidence that
dominic cummings uh gave to the science
of the technology committee yesterday
particularly as regards
at the ability or the inability of the
department of health to manage the
covert 19 crisis in its early stages
well there were obviously massive
problems and he highlighted the ones
around
ppe we saw frontline workers
who were not properly protected in our
nhs in our care
system in our transport system as well
and i i heard from
a woman who lost her father who drove a
bus to and from ealing hospital
every day and ended up dying in that
hospital because he wasn't properly
protected
so look we know there are problems there
i would say to dominic cummings though
you played a role as well and you
undermined public trust in the system
when you travel to county durham and
barnard castle
um and and so he's got to take some of
the responsibilities as well for what
happened
um last year but i think that
increasingly
voices from all sides in the political
spectrum
but most importantly the voices of the
believed families have got to be heard
when they say
that there must be a public inquiry and
that's why
i'm putting my my support behind that as
well because as i said at the beginning
there
the stories that i heard from breed
families that will stay with me forever
and i think we've got to be led by those
people
who have suffered most in the last year
and hear their pleas and their demands
for that public inquiry that they need
and we need as a country
ms reeves i'm afraid we have to leave it
there don't think i didn't see that copy
of your book just over your left
shoulder there as well
rachel reeves thanks very much for
joining us on the program
it's still to come on the program uh
well as the pandemic restrictions
continue to ease into the summer we'll
speak to a scientist about a new study
it looks at what impact if any different
different
climates have uncovered
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of
gas being fired all around us
india's fatality rate is less than two
percent one of the lowest in the world
the concern here is that the public
health care system
is inadequate
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modern decisive victory
these students and now they're going to
be arrested
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is shared that over 200 people
might have died because of these
landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast for wherever you
are welcome to
the safety ridge monday podcast for the
ones who want to know more welcome to
the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news story
cast
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that if we make
small changes to our lives we can reduce
air pollution by
loads but how much exactly
loads rain again for eastern parts of
the country that'll gradually spill in
from the east across east anglia in the
southeast as the day goes on making it
feel quite cool there
other various thing variable amounts of
cloud but some sunshine too
i should think central and southern
scotland north west england parts of
west wales seeing some of the best of
the weather today
and here warm as well a few spots
getting up to around 16
to potentially 18 celsius in scotland
now for most places there are low levels
of air pollution but in towns and near
busy roads
it could be moderate in a few spots
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
a world meteorological organization task
team
is warning against using weather
conditions to determine whether to ease
coronavirus restrictions
after issuing its first report looking
at weather and
air quality having an impact on covid19
tasty member and met office scientist
rosa bartiella
joins us now on the program rosa great
to have you on
um just explain if you can the the the
link
if there is indeed any link between
climate conditions
and covered transmission
yes good morning thank you um yes so so
as you said the
the world meteorological organization
convened a team of international and
entities
disciplinary experts last summer
to product to provide a rapid review of
of those meteorological and air quality
factors that potentially could be
affecting
the kobit 19 pandemic and what our
report found
was that transition transmission
dynamics
appear to have been controlled primarily
by government interventions rather than
by
those meteorological and air quality
factors
and when i say meteorological i mean
things like temperature humidity
or solar radiation for example
and we'll just just on that topic then
because we have heard
not just from the british government but
from from
from other governments a very obvious
link being made between
the wintertime and covered 19
transmission and
perhaps increased risk is that then on
the basis of what you see and
you're speaking from a meteorological
standpoint of course but on the basis of
what you see
is that then less to do with the
environmental conditions and rather more
to do with
common cold so on
um so yes it's a good question and
and if i could a little bit of context
to say that
we we have to take into account that
this is a new a new virus a new disease
it didn't exist 15 months
ago and so what we um know
now given you know that is only um
limited research that is being produced
and only one year really is is being um
is passed is that at this stage
really the evidence does not support the
use of meteorological factors as
the basis for government to to relax
their interventions because
those meteorological conditions cannot
be unequivocally
attributable to reduced rates of
transmission
and there is some laboratory
very controlled studies that seem to
suggest
that dividers survives longer
in cold dry and low ultraviolet
or solar radiation conditions however
these
studies have not yet indicated if direct
methodological
influences on the virus have meaningful
influence on the transmissions rate and
the real-world conditions
um just in terms of of your report of
course you've been looking at that you
know
you've been examining the circumstances
you know when people are outside and
if you're talking about seasonality that
that that makes sense but i wonder if
there is anything in your report
that might lend some weight to or or
might suggest
strategies in terms of ventilation in
terms of
air filters in terms of increasing air
flow through
at places like well the studio that i'm
speaking to you from at the moment
um yes so
um that was that was completely out
of the scope um in this report um
and we didn't look at
any kind of interventions or indeed we
didn't look at
any kind of indoor for example air
quality
we just focused on outdoor air quality
and um yeah the meteorological
conditions that i mentioned earlier
so unfortunately um yes i'm not
qualified to talk about that
rosa not a problem but but on that basis
then so where does the task team take
its efforts next
yeah so as you mentioned there there was
um a lot of discussion or there has been
a lot of discussion about seasonality
and the underlying mechanisms direct or
indirect
and and whether or not this potentially
could
become seasonal over time so we are
thinking about um exactly you know what
are the topics
perhaps that could be more useful to
national mail services
in terms of addressing those potential
you know opportunities if these fighters
were to become a transition
um where to become seasonal over time
then there might be a case for
using meteorological and air quality
information
to support monitoring of forecasting of
of of this of these spiders but i would
like to add as well that
what we'd like to see is this report
being
yet another tool and piece of
information that decision makers
and the government will use um in
a combination with the many other
you know information and studies that
are out there
rosa bartiella great to talk to you this
morning thanks for joining us
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
some interesting contrast in the weather
today eastern parts of the country
rather cool
and gray and damp actually some rain
comes in from the north sea
but there'll be others that see some
good chunks of sunshine developing after
a rather cloudy start in fact
i should think across northern england
and scotland through this afternoon
temperatures could well reach
16 to potentially 18 celsius it just
becomes beautiful
in some of these northern areas through
today maybe northern coast cool and grey
but inland
lots of sunshine and really feeling very
pleasant indeed compared to that damp
and dreary and breezy
east coast there that rain comes in
london weakens actually overnight
tonight but it could get stuck across
some central areas tomorrow giving a
cool gray day
either side of that bank of cloud though
some sunshine and plenty of blue sky for
tomorrow afternoon
across southeast britain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you coming up in the next
hour on sky news breakfast the housing
secretary told us
there will be a slowdown in the uk's
vaccine rollout because of
global supply issues we'll have more
next